the faithful gathered inside and outside
Saint Mary's cathedral in Sydney former
conservative Prime Ministers Tony Abbott
and John Howard were amongst the
mourners in short
he's the greatest Catholic Australia has
produced
and one of our country's greatest Sons
the Archbishop of Sydney led the service
describing Cardinal George Pell as a
giant of the Catholic church in
Australia he was also controversial and
the most senior Roman Catholic convicted
of sexual abuse Pell spent more than a
year in prison before the convictions
were overturned by the high court it
caused division within the church a
point acknowledged in his final farewell
but if some experienced him as demanding
pugilistic
or polarizing
and others as faithful
hospitable
and witty
it's now the turn of the Saints
to endure his teasing lecturing and
commands outside hundreds gathered to
show their anger despite being
exonerated in 2020 Pearl's detractors
remained critical of him
[Applause]
survivors of child sexual abuse led the
rally confronting mourners at Thursday's
service
this is a private
funeral for an individual and it's
completely different he was um a
pedophile facilitator and he couldn't be
looked at in any other way that's how we
should be remembered a man that thought
you know hurting children and abusing
children was okay basically just to show
so
old pal
died in Rome last month he'll be buried
at St Mary's Cathedral where he
previously served as Archbishop Sarah
Clarke Al Jazeera